foreign let's get the latest on what the
UK government is doing to help those
affected by the earthquakes I'm joined
now by the foreign office Minister
Andrew Mitchell Andrew Mitchell good
morning to you and thanks for being with
us let's get straight into the UK
response we understand that 76 experts
have been sent to Turkey here they
arrived
no the uh they're leaving this morning
they'll arrive in daylight today they
were already at Birmingham Airport to
leave last night but the most important
early lesson of this is that the first
72 hours are critical and that means
close coordination with the Turkish
authorities who are themselves highly
competent and what we're sending is 76
Specialists with the relevant equipment
with four sniffer dogs they will be
operating in daylight today under
Turkish command and I know that they're
going to make a very big impact when
they get there along with all the other
International and coordinated services
that are deployed and that coordination
is important is that why they're leaving
today rather than last night to make
sure that it's a joined up effort once
they get in country that's that's
correct I mean it's closely coordinated
with the Turkish authorities this is a
an appalling catastrophe in Turkey
Turkey a country that is very close to
Britain and which has also been host to
uh hundreds of thousands of refugees
millions of refugees who have gone there
so gazantium is a place I visited a few
years ago as part of the Syria relief
effort it's a densely populated area and
the calamitous effects of all of this
will will be quite extraordinary now
these experts that we're sending are Mr
Mitchell was that uh sent off our own
back or was this a direct request
because of course as you know you know
the area turkey does have expertise in
dealing with this kind of disaster no
the first thing we did when the news
broke yesterday morning was to speak to
the Turkish government to find out what
we could do to help we've learned a lot
of lessons since the earthquake in Haiti
where everyone piled in and the thing
didn't work well the coordination was
non-existent so we've learned that
lesson and we take our lead purely from
the Turkish government we find out what
the Turkish government wants and we do
our very best to supply it and the
Turkish government asked for the support
and that's why we are dispatching the 76
experts and the four sniffer dogs and
also deploying an emergency medical team
to help with the assessment but I can't
stress enough to your viewers that it is
the first 72 hours where we're 24 hours
plus into that now it is the first 72
hours when a coordinated response will
save the most lives and was that a
direct call between between president
erdogan
I think it was between the foreign
office and the relevant authorities in
Turkey but the Prime Minister has
expressed very strong support and has
promised that Britain will be there by
turkey's side helping at the supporting
time for the Turkish people yeah you
made that very clear Mr Michelle I
appreciate that I wonder what what more
do you think the UK government can do to
help but what the UK government can do
is to respond to the needs that the
Turkish government set out and that is
what we're going to do we stand ready
we're in constant contact uh with uh
coordinators and organizers and we stand
ready to help in any way that we can
do you have any concerns about the
amount of Aid that we're able to give
considering the fact that the aid budget
has been cut recently
well you're right V8 budget is under
very considerable strain but but Britain
always carves out a certain amount cope
with humanitarian crises that is what
people in Britain expect us to do
Britain is always there uh first and in
strength to help when these appalling
catastrophes take place and we will be
there this time and the humanitarian
budget is is in a way slightly separate
from the steady state International
Development budget and it is there
specifically to respond to crises like
these so this essentially comes from an
emergency fund rather than the sort of
overarching a foreign aid budget that we
have no it's all part of the same budget
but there is within that budget
different areas of activity and the
humanitarian activity as we've seen for
example in the Horn of Africa with the
Dreadful drought that threatens so many
young lives there the humanitarian
budget is is very carefully coordinated
and set and it reacts to the need on the
ground you can never tell at the
beginning of the year what humanitarian
crises are going to to take place and
therefore it has to be a flexible part
of what we do yeah and with the scale of
This Disaster Mr Mitchell and with your
calls recently to try and make sure that
the a budget is increased do you think
those calls will be strengthened by what
we've seen an hour only day into this
disaster well we are quite deliberately
finding ways of boosting the budget as
you say it was cut back some years ago
it's now at 0.55 it will return to 0.7
when the economic circumstances allow
but we have other ways of sweating what
the the assets that we use the money
that we deploy but I want to stress that
the humanitarian approach is slightly
different because it has to be very
elastic because we never know what
humanitarian emergencies will emerge
during the course of the year yeah and
as we mentioned turkey does have
infrastructure to deal with this sort of
thing but of course across the border in
Northwest Syria there is no
infrastructure to deal with that how is
the UK going to be helping that region
that has been affected well you're quite
right the the the area of of Northern
Syria is is is right in in the center of
all of this tragedy it's ungoverned
space part of the problem is it's very
difficult to get resources that are now
needed across the border from Turkey
partly because turkey's got its own
problems but also because there's only
one uh Crossing place and we hope that
the UN will be able to negotiate
additional uh Crossing places we have
supported for many years the white
helmets in Syria which was a civil
defense grouping that helped people who
were caught up in the and joined the
Syrian crisis and Britain funds them and
we will continue to support them they
are active we know already in helping
with this Dreadful crisis and Britain
will continue to support them but to be
clear any Aid that goes into Northwest
Syria will have to come through turkey
through the gilbertosua crossing border
you're not planning on bringing Aid
directly into the northwest of Syria
it's very difficult to get Aid in we
will use anything we can to to get Aid
to people who are desperately needed and
we're talking and closely call
coordinating with the United Nations but
if you look at the geography the the
weigh-in is from Turkey it's over that
border which is very constricted
um and that's an additional problem at a
desperate time for people who've already
suffered so much in Northern Syria thank
you for that Mr Mitchell I know we don't
have much time with you but I do want to
ask you something about domestic
politics of course there's a mini
reshuffle that's going to be announced
in the next few hours uh if you asked to
be a chairperson of the party would you
take it
the these are matters way above my pay
grade the matters for the Prime Minister
but I'm obviously very honored to be
doing the development job in the foreign
office and I'm going to get on today and
in the days to come focusing on this
terrible tragedy in turkey and Syria I
appreciate that Anthony Talia denial Mr
Mitchell I'll take it from you but thank
you very much for your time this morning
Andrew Mitchell there thank you